after a case of pneumonia nearly caused
her to collapse this past weekend the
conspiracy theorist of Twitter
acclaiming that Hillary Clinton has been
replaced with a body double which
they've proven using a defunct version
of Photoshop and control-v right here
coincidentally this also has to be a
picture of Bill Clinton's worst
nightmare
a comedians assuming the same people who
believe Barack Obama is a Muslim from
outer space are correct
what are some of the duties of Hillary's
body double K Walsh also beating Donald
Trump in a landslide all right Jim
Jefferies staying home with Bill's body
double while he's at the strip club all
right boys Bhutto she's her secret
shopper she has to go try on the
high-waisted pleated pants to make sure
it does no camel yeah although it's fine
if you sing it like that then it's
alright Hamilton